[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
thank you all for coming on the last day
of classes in our last colloquium i'm
really excited today to have alexandra
toe she's an assistant professor at
northeastern uh jointly appointed in the
art and design or games department in
the college of art media and design and
the curry college of computer science
her core research interests are in
studying and designing social
technologies to empower people in
marginalized contexts and she uses
qualitative methods to gather counter
stories
and participatory methods
to design for the future she
additionally has extensive experience
leading teams of educational game
designers and has designed award-winning
games
and professor toe is a racial justice
activist a critical race scholar and a
game designer and she received her phd
in human commuter
human computer interaction hci from
carnegie mellon university as well as a
bs and ms in symbolic systems with a
minor in asian american studies from
stanford university so welcome to
professor toad
take it away
awesome thank you so much for that warm
welcome is everyone see my slides okay
okay fantastic yeah um
uh so yeah as uh heather said right i um
work in the area of racial justice games
and hci i'm very excited to be here with
all of you today to talk about some of
my ongoing work and this idea of
center
centering people of color in the design
of games
and what that looks like and what
opportunities are available there
so yeah you know just just
very close by at northeastern and boston
sorry couldn't come in person today but
hopefully we'll be able to connect in
person sometime soon in the future
uh yeah so i i always like to start out
uh talks giving a little bit more
context about about who i am i think
that that's always useful is like a kind
of a you know
relationship like feminist standpoint
theory right like i think in order to
understand the work i'm doing and the
context i do it from like you need that
information
um and yeah and this also is a bit of a
new style of talk for me i usually only
present on like very completed and
finished and like not thinking about it
anymore work but this is
an opportunity for me to try something a
little new i wanted to talk to you all
about my ongoing research so it's
imperfect it's in progress but i was
hoping that it would give us some good
food for thought for discussion
afterwards
um yeah so as already stated right i'm
an assistant professor at northeastern
i'm in art and design in the games group
and the college of computer science uh
and i work in this intersection of hci
games and critical race theory or racial
justice and the venues that i publish
tend to be in intersections of those
spaces uh so acm venues like kai and kai
play dis fdg
games journals and conferences like
digra and meaningful play
and when i do do the work that i do i'm
trying to approach
it from this lens of empowerment um so
this
lens of empowerment when i say that i
mean there's sort of two very specific
tactics that i try to use in my work uh
the first being visibility there's a lot
of different kinds of visibility but for
the purpose of the projects i'm talking
about today i mean increasing the
visibility of people of color as already
being present in games as being powerful
and a very diverse uh group of people
who have different needs and desires
and the second tactic i try to use in my
work is this idea of self-determination
which is trying to think about how do we
take power and distribute it so people
who are the most vulnerable have agency
and impact on the design deployment and
use of technologies which does include
things like games
and also as heather stated for my bio i
tend to use two major categories of
methods in my work
i use qualitative research methods so
for me that looks like documenting
stories trying to move people from the
margins to the center
doing storytelling work that challenges
dominant narratives through the telling
of counter stories
and then i also do design research so
when i say i design
i don't design things that are meant to
be solutions like the final sort of end
solution for any problem that i'm
studying they're more meant to be
artifacts that help highlight
assumptions or
exaggerate underlying dynamics that
maybe aren't quite as visible i do
participatory design research which
involves bringing many different kinds
of people to the table in design
processes to think about designing
better or more joyful or more empowered
futures
yeah
so yeah i and again right i do a lot of
this through the lens of games because i
love games um so the the games on the
screen are games that are like
particularly memorable to me um they're
all digital games but i'm also a big fan
of tabletop games and board games the
ones on the left are like the memorable
games of my childhood that like first
engaged me in this idea of games and the
ones on the right are like the ones that
i've approached more in adulthood and
i've enjoyed played playing recently
things like that
um
but unfortunately right games uh do not
always love me back um this quotation at
the top is from tonya de pass uh who's
the founder of i need diverse games from
this documentary she did about her work
recently
um and for me right when i'm thinking
about working in this field and
use approaching it from a lens of of
social justice and specifically racial
justice right i always think it's
important to acknowledge that there's
a middle ground between
finding something problematic and trying
to cut it out of your life or cut it out
of your heart um or loving something so
much that it can never be critiqued
right critiquing the media that we
consume and that we enjoy is for me a
really important part of that process
and a really joyful part of that process
so i wanted to share this like brief
anecdote um about uh my favorite game um
dragon age origins is my actual favorite
game of all time um i think it came out
sometime around 2008 or 2009.
um it's very much the game that made me
realize that gaming was an important
part of who i am my identity like things
i wanted to pursue in life
but i also will never forget this
kind of like negative unpleasant
experience i had the first time i played
it um so this is an image of the
character creation system dragon age
origins it's a role play fantasy
role-playing game
and it has one of those like you know
make your own character systems that has
like all of this level of detail right
there's like you can see on here just
for skin there's like skin tone and
complexion and your eye color and your
if you've got tattoos or things like
that the game has a bunch of different
hair colors and hair textures
um so i think like a lot of people i
spent
well over an hour
really trying hard to make this
character that looked like me that was
what i wanted at the time was to play
someone who looked like me um
and i was really happy with what i ended
up with in the end and like finally
started playing the game
but then early in the game um on the
human noble uh path which is like one of
six paths you can choose uh you get to
meet your parents uh so these are
pictures of the the in-game parents that
you meet um and they're both very
clearly very visibly white
which isn't you know necessarily
going to immediately break that
immersion right they don't refer to why
you might look different than your
parents like there could be a number of
totally reasonable explanations for that
so it wasn't really that experience that
was that jarring it was like a little
bit of a of a hint of what was to come
for me
but then later in the sort of
introduction story you're speaking to
the person the character who's your
mother
and there's this stranger there who's
like a friend of hers
and she
uh brings up this like incident in the
household that happened like earlier
that day or earlier that week and she
like reprimands you and scolds you and
for me that completely took me out of
the game
because in my family with my different
cultural backgrounds and histories right
like uh being scolded and
by your parents in front of someone
who's outside the family is just
something completely inconceivable that
would never happen and that was that
moment for me of like realizing like oh
this game system gave me the ability to
make someone who physically looks a bit
like me but ultimately this game is not
representative of who i am as a person
this is like really serious cultural
things happening
that like
i think we're designed to be open to
like many different kinds of people but
really was very representative of a very
white experience that like did not
resonate with me at all
and it is worth noting that since then
um
bioware the company that makes dragon
age has done a couple of different
things to experiment with like how to
address this in other games in dragon
age 2 they tried this new interesting
system of uh using the character you
made in character creation to then model
the family members you meet later to
look kind of like that
um but in the most recent dragon age
they just removed your family members
you never actually see them in the game
it's just like not they're referenced in
text but you never actually physically
see them so they've skirted their
problem entirely in the most recent um
installation of the game
uh so this kind of brings me to the
topic of the talk today which is
thinking about like what are the
opportunities that are available when we
center the experiences of black
indigenous and people of color
what does that allow what is enable what
is exciting about thinking about games
from that approach
and i do i mean from like a lot of
different aspects i think the
conversation around representation can
often get really oversimplified that's
how you end up with situations like this
where it's like oh we let you make a
person of color it's like yeah but you
didn't actually right how do we think
about this problem a little bit more
deeply
all right so yeah so today i'm gonna i'm
gonna kind of explore this idea through
three different ongoing projects i have
but i wanna just dip into a little brief
background on race and games first
um and really the the important
background knowledge here is just that
like this concept is not a new concept
right so i mentioned that in the talk
abstract um
people of color have always been in
games right as game designers and
developers and players and critics um so
this idea is not particularly new
um but we can start thinking about how
can we push that agenda harder and
further and actually center those
experiences
in the game design
at the early stages of the work
and i really like this quotation as well
but i also put in the abstract from
keyshawn and gray who i believe you all
had here last year she talks about how
gaming is a really good site for inquiry
for resistance and activism and
mobilization amongst marginalized users
so the other other bit of background i
wanted to share in terms of how i
approach this work is the lens of
transformational gains
um so
um i i partially use this because a lot
of the work that i do when i'm designing
games is designing transformational
games
so you may have also heard these
referred to as serious games or
educational games or games for change
but i like the the lens of
transformation because it looks at a
much broader kind of transformation
but essentially it's this idea right
that that games are an incredibly
powerful tool
for
uh allowing transformation to happen in
the game and then to be taken to the out
of game context right it has the ability
to alter how we think what we know what
we believe how we act um all of these
different sort of you know uh
range of emotional to psychological to
physical experiences are possible with
this like very interactive medium so i
wanted to give just a couple examples of
that if you're not quite as familiar
with transformational games right if we
look at a
an app like duolingo um that uses
gamified elements right to teach
language learning it's something that
happens in the context of that game but
then is taken outside of it
buffalo is a card game it's a
transformational card game that helps
battle internal stereotypes
never alone is a really beautiful video
game
that engages players in learning the
culture and folklore of inyupaya
indigenous peoples
and then rosenstrassa is a tabletop
role-playing game that explores the
erosion of civil rights in 1930s and 40s
berlin through sort of historical
fiction role play of a real life set of
protests that happened in berlin at that
time
uh yet another kind of category of games
i want us to to be thinking about as
we're talking about this work is this
idea of like counter space games um
counter space games i think can also be
thought of as maybe a subset or a type
of transformational game
where we're taking a counter space which
is a safe space for members of a
marginalized group
that allows for identity
expression and celebration
and designing those into games um so
this is work that is um
defined by erica principe cruz he's a
colleague of mine uh where she wrote
that you know counter space games
leverage these like highly interactive
and powerful affordances of games
and play to cultivate psychological
safety interdependence and collective
joy in the way that a real life counter
space would work
so we're going to kind of take all these
concepts together and then look at these
three different projects
so the first project i want to talk to
you about is looking at how gamers of
color specifically black sims players
are already remaking and creating game
content that centers those lived
experiences i was talking about
so this project is in collaboration with
angela dr smith who's at ut austin
and
this is taking a look at the community
that she had the chance to participate
in
um is a bit involved in herself and
she's starting to notice some really
interesting trends in how that community
engages in game modifications
so for those of you who aren't familiar
the sims is a simulation game it is one
of the best-selling pc franchises and uh
the current most recent release is the
sims 4. so there have been four versions
of the game um over the past couple
decades they also tend to release a lot
of expansion packs with a lot of new
content at regular base
intervals this screenshot is from one of
their more recent releases which was i
believe a spa day pack
um
so the gameplay in the sim uh typically
just kind of models everyday life
usually of people who are in the suburbs
this screenshot is from the first
version of the sims
and that very early version of the game
the first one that was released was
celebrated as being quite socially
progressive
it doesn't have simulation
of the kinds of oppressive systems that
we have in our society or had in our
society at the time there isn't
racism or sexism in the game it allowed
for same-sex relationships which was um
really unusual at the time that the
first game was released
and modding is a big part of gameplay in
the sims um so the creation
by game players of their own
custom content or custom traits or other
ways of changing the actual format of
the game
is a big part of the gameplay it's like
um something that the publishers allow
for relatively easily
so the kinds of custom content you might
see would be things like
um
different uh houses in the game you can
see here like this is the sim is in a
house like you can release different
designs clothing skin tones hair
textures makeup in the game
more recently there's a lot more like
meta gameplay modding so you can
actually change some of the ai behaviors
of the sims you can allow them to do
different kinds of interactions um
follow different job pass you can give
them different personality traits that
again affects like their ai and how they
interact with other sims and with the
world around them
and i also want to talk a little bit
about who the sims players are right so
this is a very popular video game
franchise the most recent version has
well over 33 million players and the
majority of those players are young
women so specifically women who are aged
18 to 24 and that's part of why i think
this is such an important game or games
in the genre are important to look at
because when we talk about games
research and games work that's an
audience that we tend to overlook even
though the majority or quite a large
demographic of game players in the us
are women over 30 we don't tend to think
of the kinds of games that they play and
enjoy as being the like mainstream games
when in fact they actually are
um so what we wanted to explore with
this initial study in this like modding
behavior is why are black simmers
modding the sims like what kinds of
content do they want um what is the
motivation behind those things and then
like when they're actually modding what
is the kind of content that they're
creating and using
uh so like i mentioned this is uh very
ongoing work i think as of this morning
we've conducted i believe seven
interviews so these are one hour
interviews that we're doing over zoom
and the participants have all been
recruited from a black simmers facebook
group which has got
thousands of people in it who are
sharing game mods they share screenshots
of their gameplay with stories attached
to them
they help each other out and like post
like youtube tutorials and things like
that about how to
um create
mods yourself or how to install mods or
do things like that
um so some of the questions that we ask
in this interview study are you know
what kind of content is essential to
your game play um whether that's content
from the base game or expansion packs or
mods that you either have
made yourself or that you've downloaded
from other creators we asked them to
tell us a little bit about their
favorite sim households who are the
player characters in that household what
do they do what are their personalities
what's important about them or enjoyable
about them to you
and then for people who create mods we
ask them like what mods have you created
and why have you done that um and then
if you if for folks who have only used
mods we asked them like well if you
could create any mod you wanted what
would it be and like why would you want
that in the game
uh so um because this is ongoing we
haven't done formal data analysis we've
been doing things kind of on a rolling
basis debriefing so i did want to share
a couple of early quotations and themes
that are starting to emerge with this
work
uh so the first is just looking at like
what does representation in the context
of this game look like and what does it
mean and what's important about that
so we have a couple quotations here from
different participants right talking
about one participant really wanted to
focus on uh black women um in their
games as a non-binary participant but
who really wanted to explore the sort of
softer feminine aesthetic of black women
and they felt like that was a form of
resistance against
the ways that black women might be
stereotypically represented in other
games or other game genres so they
talked about hairstyles as being part of
that as clothing being a part of that
but then also these sort of other
ways that the sims interacted again with
other sims and with the world
we had other other participants talk
about
again going deeper on those
relationships interactions right when my
sim is talking to other sims what are
they talking about are they talking
about things that reflect the real
relationships of people that i know in
my in my life or other you know um
communities that i've interacted with
but this isn't something
that um uh uh
that the participants necessarily wanted
everyone to have access to so we had
this sort of note from from one of the
participants about ebonics right so she
said that she did want ebonics to be in
the game so or you know aave
african-american vernacular english but
she didn't want that to be broadly
accessible like to the sims in the game
or to other people who play the sims
right she was mentioning like this is
you know i would love to see this
represented but i don't necessarily want
my white sims to have access to that
that wouldn't be appropriate
and i have a couple screenshots here
again just of like what some of these
mods look like so the one in the
background is a trait mod for anime
lover that a very popular sim mod
creator released um so again this
changes the personality of the sim and
what they talk about and what they like
and how they interact with other sims
then the screenshot in the front here is
um different a makeup release mod so
this was um
this creator created different lip
glosses that looked good on black sims
and released that to the public so
anyone could download it
and the second big theme i wanted to
highlight today from the sort of
preliminary very informal analysis we've
done is going deeper into what does
representation actually mean and what's
the purpose of representation
um so a lot of participants were
speaking about reality and in fact i
believe every participant that we've
interviewed so far has at some point
brought up
the idea of making the game more
realistic um so we wanted to like
interrogate that idea a little bit like
when every when every single person's
saying that what do you actually mean by
realistic
um and it looks like representing
aspects of culture that are not
already included in the base game right
so we had some participants talk about
changing the entire neighborhood so it
was filled with other people of color
so that the interactions that their sims
had in the neighborhood were more
reflective of what real life might look
like
um
a lot of them talk about how the mods
are essential to that you cannot do that
with the game as it's already built uh
there were a lot of other intersectional
identity concerns right there are other
aspects beyond race that participants in
the study really cared about um things
about sexuality about body
representation
um you know other you know less identity
relevant things like the jobs that are
accessible or what the actual um
neighborhoods and cities look like in
the game
it's just a way of reflecting reality
and specifically reality as a pathway to
immersion
so immersion or escapism is a really big
part of why a lot of people play games
no matter what the genre is but when
that game doesn't reflect reality right
very much in the way of the anecdote
that i share at the beginning with my
own gameplay it really pulls you out of
it it can be very jarring um so creating
these mods and using these mods are a
way of again
having the game actually reflect what
the world around us actually looks like
so with the second project i wanted to
share today i move a little bit away
from studying games and look more into
making games
specifically the goal of this second
project was to make a game that
represented the experiences of students
of color at predominantly white
institutions or colleges us this is done
with um
students chris jamie dilruba and davina
so to give a little bit more background
in why this was the motivation behind
the project
when you look at the literature on the
experiences of black indigenous and
students of color at pwis the majority
of the literature tends to focus on
sort of pathologizing the student of
color experience right tends to focus on
achievement gaps and attrition
and the disadvantages those students are
at and while there is a certain amount
of reality in there the
the sort of over-representation of these
sort of
traumas and sort of deficit lens of
students of color i think is really
detrimental to how we think about how we
talk about how we center those students
right that is um it's missing a big part
of what that experience actually is
so some of the work that does focus on
sort of more
joyful experiences or powerful
experiences that students of color have
look at things like cultural centers as
this
site for
identity relevant work specifically uh
there's a paper last year by leanne
hippolyte that was exploring what is it
about black cultural centers that are so
effective at increasing feelings of
belongingness or just being a space that
is like comfortable and safe for black
students
and really the main
mechanism that she found that was
effective was this idea of seeing other
people have gone through the same things
as you right you could imagine a
situation of being
one of a few number of students in your
classes as a freshman
but when you're going to cultural
centers you're able to meet students in
other departments
students who are older than you people
who have gone through the same
experiences that you have and getting
being able to see
uh something like a role model or just
that your experience is not isolated is
incredibly powerful
so that was sort of the motivation of
exploring this with the game
i wanted to
create a game narrative experience that
did that same thing that showed that
these experiences are shared by other
people
real life experiences of navigating
these situations that would do that sort
of same thing of showing other kinds of
role models
and i will add to that that of course
like ultimately
what is really necessary there is that
we advocate for those resources for
resources for cultural centers at
universities
but again this sort of game design
exploration work is a way of looking at
other alternative ways of trying to to
share that that mechanism that is so
helpful and potentially powerful
uh so in some of my previous work um if
we're talking about representation and
and how games um do or do not represent
diverse
people's well
um i looked at a bunch of different
tactics that games are already using um
to to achieve good identity
representations this is not just for
race but for other aspects of identity
and in analyzing a bunch of games that
actually do have relatively good diverse
representation i came up with this list
of five design tactics
um so you know there is visual design
that can be an important part of
representation in games
but there are also all of these other
game system things that you can be doing
that will uh make that representation
more than just physical appearance right
so the setting and roles the way you
design conversations the rule design the
abstract representation of characters
are all ways of doing that
so for me
the nice thing about this project was
also an excuse to put some of this work
into action this was all sort of an
analysis of existing games that were
published and available on the market
but i wanted to be able to take some of
this work of mine from a couple of years
ago and put it into action into active
design work
so in addition to lenses of critical
race theory in my work i also
incorporate intersectionality and in my
games work i often lean very heavily on
queer theory specifically queer game
studies
so as my team and i were conceiving of
what does this project look like what
does the game design work look like
we're looking to extend some of beau
ruberg's work on queer games to think
about what does it look like to make a
game that is designed by for and about
people of color um and then the sort of
second question that we're exploring
with this project is how do we actually
accurately and faithfully capture the
experiences of black indigenous and
students of color at predominantly white
institutions in this game context while
respecting and treating those stories
well
um
so
we worked on the game design um for this
proposed game for about three to four
months um last year in the fall and
spring
um and the sort of conclusion that we
came to at the end of that prototyping
work that we did
was a couple of things
the first was that it was just
incredibly special to get to engage in
that process of making a game that was
again
five for and about people of color
so i had the chance to work with two
students of color in this project a lot
of our early work on the project was
just all of the preparation of setting
ourselves up for success
so we spent a lot of time figuring out
how to make a creative design space in
our project meetings that allowed us to
deal with topics that can be sensitive
or that can feel a bit taboo when you're
dealing with people that you are just
working with for the first time
making sure that we found ways to
acknowledge and uplift each other's
humanity making sure that it was a safe
place to
share vulnerable experiences to design
around those to interact with them with
each other and also make sure that we're
doing good and rigorous work
so these are just a couple of examples
of what we did that i'm hoping others
can incorporate into design processes
one of them is
creating a shared list of agreements or
community agreements that very much
comes from my work in racial justice
spaces where you have to think about
like what kinds of values are you going
to uphold in the space and how do you
make sure that everyone is accountable
to those values including supervisors
um
so yeah the goal ultimately was to kind
of create an environment where
vulnerability is uh welcome but it's not
required and that's another really
important aspect of that
um so again the the conclusions that we
came through right so one it was like
very affirming and exciting to do this
right um
this was for me
in the space like one of the first times
i've shared with students specifically
what it was like for me to to be in
college
as a mixed race person the experiences
that i had that were uplifting and
affirming like student activism the bad
experiences that i had being questioned
about my own identities and the students
did the same
which i was really excited about because
it gave me
space to write about those things and
some of my other work
um so we actually ended up publishing a
short paper just about the design
process there was already so much we
found out just getting to do that work
together
um so a couple of the things that we
write about that short paper about what
that looks like and feels like to do
this sort of bipod game design process
was that like yes it is a little bit
scary uh we found out that a lot of the
game design conventions that um are
taught to game students and game
scholars don't actually apply in this
scenario
so one example for us early in the
process was we were making a tower
defense game
and
one convention in games is that uh
because of
[Music]
things like growth mindset that are
built very well into games where if you
fail at something it's
sort of psychologically acceptable
because you always come back to life you
get to try again
that simply doesn't apply when the
entire audience or the entire cast of
game characters are students of color at
a white academic institution watching
students of color die or fail over and
over again in the context of the game it
doesn't really have that same impact
that like is written about in many
different game design theory books
um so you know
there's a bit of pressure when it comes
to doing that kind of game design but
for the most part it's an incredibly
joyful and affirming process to
incorporate those kinds of values into a
design process
so a lot of what we did was try to
empower each other to speak up to say
when an idea for the game was harmful or
when it needed to be thrown out because
it wasn't working
and it was very joyful to just see like
mundane everyday representation our
narrative designer chris wrote a bunch
of scenes of just students going to the
cafeteria together and studying together
doing these things and just getting to
see
students of color in that environment
doing everyday things
was like surprisingly powerful for all
of us because we realized we didn't have
media that that showed much of that
prior to our work trying to spin this up
on the game
so beyond all those process things that
we learned the other thing that we
learned was that yes we did have enough
juice as a team to create a game
prototype just filling it with our own
experiences but at the end of the day
that was not enough to build out a whole
game and we had to actually return to
uh sort of old standby for me which is
collecting people's stories there are
just not
publicly available narratives about what
it's like to be a college student of
color at a pwi we had a lot to share
from our own personal experiences and
the experiences of colleagues and
friends but ultimately if we want to
actually do this properly and do it
faithfully we needed to go back and
actually collect more data and more
stories about this
uh so this is another ongoing interview
study that's happening in my lab
where again we're kind of asking
questions about sources of joy and
strength and resilience as a student of
color at a pwi and then asking questions
about like what was surprising um what
were you anticipating what went well
what were some things that like you wish
you had been more prepared for for those
experiences
um and even though we're not at the
design phase right now it is this work
is trying to take on a bit of a spirit
of uh assets based design
in treating our audience students of
color pwis as experts and treating those
experiences as valuable and something
that we should center the design around
so again i wanted to share just a couple
of preliminary quotations from our early
data analysis um
this study i also believe we have around
six or seven participants completed at
this point we're pausing data collection
until we pick things back up again in
january
um but yeah
a lot of the findings are unsurprisingly
about the need for counter spaces
and
part of what we're trying to do again is
drill down on the specifics there so we
have students who are talking about like
what it was like to be in a space that
leveled the power dynamics between
faculty staff and students so everyone
could engage with these ideas of
diversity and inclusion so you could run
programming where everyone is in a space
of learning together
there was a lot of discussion of um what
it feels like to be able to lower your
guard when you're in a space because you
know that people are not going to come
up to you and question things about your
identity or ask you to teach them things
about yourself
and instead you can just sort of live in
the like affirmation of a space where
you know you're going to encounter other
people who have your sort of shared same
experiences
so again these findings are not
particularly surprising but what they
did offer again is very specific stories
that hopefully we can also incorporate
into our future games work in addition
to just shedding more light on what this
experience is like
beyond the sort of lens of deficits and
trauma
uh and then the last project i'll touch
on today just very briefly is another
game design project that more directly
confronts those uglier experiences of
prejudice and identity that i i
mentioned do come up in some of my
previous work but wasn't necessarily the
focus
uh so this last project um looks at
again the power of games to teach and to
transform um and also as sort of a
jumping off point for thinking about the
future in terms of speculative design
and designing for the kinds of futures
that we might want to engage with um
with other my other students doxa shinyu
hung and derba
so again once again going back to
motivations the original motivation of
this work was that i just wanted to be
doing participatory design work this is
work that happened at the end of my phd
thesis i was looking at the topic of
interpersonal racism at the time so it
was a little bit more focused on
negative and traumatic experiences
but i wanted to engage participants with
speculation and thinking about the
future of what does it look like to
be supported when these sort of negative
experiences happen
and while there are a great number of
participatory design and speculative
design exercises um that have been used
to do that kind of future thinking
um most of them were not
easily adopted to something um as
sensitive as experiences of racism
and for me
sort of the immediate thought was like
well games are are again once again a
very powerful tool for intervening in
that kind of space
because they're so immersive because um
they allow you to take on the role of
another person role-playing has been
used in those kinds of very serious
clinical contexts for dealing with
sensitive topics
and unlike reading a fictional story or
watching a movie the interactivity of
games gives a lot of agency to the
person who's playing or using them
and making choices about how they're
going to interact with the content
so if you're not familiar just a brief
definition microaggressions are subtle
sometimes unintended slights insults and
exclusions there are racial
microaggressions but there are also
microaggressions across another a number
of other forms of identity like gender
sexuality etc
so for this work what i did was wrote an
interactive fiction vignette about a
college student who experiences a racial
microaggression um so again the sort of
first person perspective allows uh
participants to engage with an
experience of racial prejudice and
aggression from a first person
perspective but without
unnecessarily
putting that participant in those actual
shoes in the way that like a deception
study or something else more
live would do
um so this story follows
a character named sam who's in a
research lab
they go to have coffee with a visiting
professor where they then encounter uh
three back-to-back racial
microaggression statements
so those are your english is so good
you're so articulate and where are you
from where are you really from where
your parents from
and at the time when i designed this
game the purpose of the game was to be
again a jumping off point for
speculative design so i asked
participants to play through the game
and then they did this design activity
where they analyzed the game and they
started to find opportunities for design
started to relate it to their own
experiences um and we did sort of
participatory design workshops um doing
those activities in groups
where then the participants produced
these like storyboards and ideas for
futuristic technologies that would
better support them through experiences
of racism or prejudice um so that that
work is a bit older the the current
ongoing work in the space um comes from
the feedback that i actually got as i
was presenting this this work um after
it was completed um which was i was
constantly getting this question about
like oh this is like
this vignette is really interesting can
you use it to teach people about
microaggressions
um so last summer i had three incredible
masters students who extended the work
they looked at different opportunities
for using the game to teach different
ideas about microaggressions so
one version
was created to look at historical
perspectives on microaggressions like
where did the stereotypes come from that
are then
harmfully
embedded into microaggressions
another version looked at
this idea of allyship and bystander
intervention so when you see a
microaggression happening how do you
recognize it label it how do you speak
up either for yourself or someone else
and then the third version
is uh mostly getting out the information
about what is a microaggression what is
it that makes it so harmful for the
people who are experiencing it so while
these first two are a little bit more
aimed at allies and accomplices who
might be able to do something when they
see it happening or who might be able to
like
learn themselves to not inflict those
other people the third version is a
little bit more about people who
experience microaggressions and
understanding like why does it make you
feel so tired or exhausted or um you
know like why does it feel harmful to
like your sense of belonging in space
when you hear these microaggressions and
part of the motivation behind this is
that a lot of people
when hearing a microaggression
will have the instinct to brush it off
and act like it doesn't matter because
it's not an overt form of prejudice but
they actually do end up being quite
psychologically harmful
um so one note i wanted to say about
this work is again this design work is
ongoing is that i'm very proud of the
work that these students have done but
one of the things that we're doing right
now is is choosing to move forward very
slowly and cautiously with these games
there are a lot of really great
empathy and learning games out there but
there are also some really bad ones that
can be more harmful um than good so what
we're doing now is doing a lot of
assessment about making sure that the
bystander interventions in the game are
validated that we're being sensitive to
the fact that these are real experiences
that people have had who are likely to
read these games
um
so we're trying to move forward sort of
cautiously in how we choose to to move
forward and release these more publicly
all right so to to wrap up today i
wanted to just summarize a couple of my
thoughts and things that i've been
learning through the process of working
on these projects and a little bit about
where i hope this work is headed uh for
myself and for other people
uh so for me
there are a couple of good opportunities
here and again center centering people
of color in a game design experience
um
the first one is just to remember when
you're doing
work that is meant to have some kind of
systemic change or you're looking to be
more inclusive the number one thing is
to look at what people who are already
working in that space are already doing
right as i mentioned up top right people
of color have always been in games
streamers developers designers etc
and there are already plenty of people
who are doing the work of reclaiming and
remaking game spaces some of them are
doing it within the games industry and
some are doing it by creating their own
communities and spheres of influence so
for me that's just a general go-to
tactic whenever i'm working in a space
where i'm looking at systemic change is
that
looking to the people who have already
been doing the work finding ways of
uplifting and supporting it and sharing
resources and spotlighting the work i
think is the the kind of first place to
go um the instinct to to always start
from scratch i think comes from a
colonial mindset that i i is a habit
that i want us as academics to break as
much as possible
um the second is not really a a
directive it's more of a of a
exciting feeling that i felt and that
i've seen other people on my teams feel
which is that like when you get the
chance to do that representation
correctly when you get to center those
experiences it really does
um
uplift the joy and humanity of all of
the people who are involved it's very
exciting in a way that like i did not
realize i was missing um when i first
started these projects
and then finally like uh it's not just
about the output right of what we're
making it's also about the processes
that we use on the way to
that ultimate design right so embedding
some of these uh
you know community values and centering
these ideas of like joy and humanity and
rest in a design process is really
another way of sort of uplifting um
all of the people who are going to be
involved in your design teams and
processes
uh so
like i said a lot of this is ongoing
work um there are still interview
studies to complete and there's gonna be
a lot of game design work that's
happening in my lab in the spring i'm
also looking um at other aspects of the
work with a couple of um
collaborations so chris martens and i
are looking at using tabletop story
games as a way to think about
speculative liberatory futures i'm also
working with christina harrington on a
more generalized design framework that
again kind of centers the cultural
values of people of color joy wellness
rest things like that
i did want to shout out really briefly a
bunch of other kinds of things that i
work on if you ever want to chat about
these or connect about some of my other
work i do a lot of work in critical race
theory and hci intersectionality and
intersectional feminism and hci
um a lot of my work also is at the meta
level of looking at
the culture of academia a short paper
that came out like a year and a half or
two years ago on lab counterculture like
how do we make academic labs that um
center equity and think about things
like power hierarchies and dynamics and
flattening those things
i do some work on scholar activism
and a bunch of other games projects that
i really enjoy
uh so with that i do want to acknowledge
my incredible collaborators as well as
my students they're the reason why i get
to do all this awesome work um this was
uh the first semester that my first year
that my lab was doing lab meetings so
we've been working a lot about sort of
ingraining
the kinds of cultural values or or just
like workplace values that we want to
ingrain the lab moving forward that's
been really exciting and joyful work for
me to get to to do with my students
so with that um thank you all again so
much for having me here and for your
time and i'm very much looking forward
to our discussion
great thank you so much um i know we're
all applauding but we're mostly muted so
but i know everyone's applying because
that was a terrific presentation um
let's uh open up to uh questions and
comments discussion with the audience
see we have just a
note from tl so interesting it's such
important work thanks for sharing
um marvez i think just put a hand up is
that correct
and then it went away anyone
i could kick us off um
it's a kind of it it's a sort of banal
question following such exciting and
interesting research but i noticed that
you were doing this uh the black simmers
from the facebook group uh study was a
collaboration with t austin and that
there was a note at the top that you had
irb approval from northeastern and there
were little details like 25 payments
participants and so on and i thought um
it might be of interest to our grad
students who are working on their theses
and formulating their methods and
constructing research studies and so on
for you to talk about how that
collaboration came about a little bit
and and funding issues and just sort of
give them a picture that would help them
as as
budding intellectuals in this area
budding scholars in this area
yeah absolutely that's a that's a really
great question
um yeah it was really interesting
because i i first met angela in 2019 we
both attended the kai conference which
if anyone who's not familiar is like the
really big hci conference in the field i
was in scotland that that year which i
think was the last conference i attended
before we went
uh
only to virtual things um so yeah at the
time
um
there wasn't that many people talking
about race at all in in the field of hci
or if they were they were tending to use
a lot of coded language
um you know like things like
marginalized or
underrepresented right never actually
saying
actually race
um so when i was attending the
conference
um and i would encourage this for any
any students who are thinking about
going to conferences or who might be
able to go or um i can find the time um
that's that was a really big value right
of going to find people who are excited
about the same topics as you so i was
like going to those sessions with like
the coded names for like part research
with vulnerable communities um i got a
chance to meet uh angela and also finda
who is the other co-first author of the
critical race theory for hci paper that
that we wrote um along with kentaro
zayama who was advisor
um
so yeah i mean
finding people that you vibe with in
academia is like one of the the biggest
uh most important things i think that
you can do like we
found that we were excited about the
same research questions and problems we
did that critical race theory paper
together and said like oh well now this
is done
uh what are other opportunities we have
to work together
so i think sometimes when you're looking
to collaborate sometimes you're looking
for someone very specific you're like oh
i know i want to work on this problem i
need someone who has this other
expertise let me go find people but in
other cases like
my uh
collaborations with angela it was like
hey let's have a meeting where we just
sit and talk about all the things that
we're excited about and let's find an
overlap and see if we can spin up a
project from there so that was very much
where that project came from
um
i was mentioning that like i'm in a
games group
angela i believe is in information
science we're trying to figure out like
where is there a good fit um with the
things that will
get us to move forward in our careers
but also give us a chance to work
together so that was a big part of that
and then in terms of the the logistics
um they ended up not being too too
difficult
um there's a lot of infrastructure at
universities for cross university
collaboration you want to work with your
irb offices and kind of figure out who
owns things a lot of the logistics come
down to like
data safety and security and things like
that so those are all logistics that
like once you know what you want to do
relatively easy to figure out you know
work with your administrators and people
and you know treat them kindly and those
things tend to work out relatively
smoothly it takes a while but it's not
too bad
great thank you um marvez is uh nixon i
believe he's having some uh video
trouble but has it's fine with audio so
we might not uh see marvis but we can
hear them
uh can everyone hear me okay
yeah okay sorry i don't know why uh my
video doesn't seem to want to cooperate
today but thank you for your talk it's
really interesting
um one uh in my lab we uh create
educational simulations to help teachers
practice like enacting moments of equity
and i'm curious how your lab goes about
balancing like authenticity with like a
simulation design like what elements of
reality do you abstract away so people
can focus on
the like microaggressions or the moments
of inequity uh yeah thanks
yeah that's a really great question and
it's like a difficult one right because
you never want to
uh accidentally trivialize things by
removing the elements that are important
um so really i think it just comes down
to like play testing and user testing
for me right like bringing
um as many stakeholders who are impacted
in as you can with the time that you
have
and making it very clear that like your
your game or your system or whatever it
is that you're working on it's not
complete it is open to change it likely
has assumptions in it that are maybe
correct or not and that when you're
bringing someone in to do a user test or
a play test like in the context of games
right that like
that person does not feel pressure to
say that it's good because of like you
know
the bias of wanting to like make you
feel good or pump you up or like say
nice things about your research trying
to encourage that that process of
iteration and critique i think is a big
part of it like i said the game
that my students and i were working on
on the student of color experience
that's right we had a couple of of major
game design overhauls right where we had
been working on this one design idea for
like a month and a half and eventually
we're like staring at it together and
we're like hey i think this is actually
potentially really harmful and it's a
very painful moment but making sure
you're building in that time and those
protections to let that happen and to
treat it like a good thing because hey
at least we're
learning something and moving forward i
think is is helpful that's also more of
a tip for supervisors maybe than for
students right but like make sure that
these timelines are not going to
sacrifice the quality of the work and
end up actually harming people
um thank you we have a question from
tomas
um who asks a a
question uh thanks for the fantastic
talk i was wondering if you thought
about any parallels between the sims and
theater as a media practice and the
strategies that marginalize public's
views
oh that's a very cool question well i
will say i'm i'm i don't know too much
about theater so that um i probably
wouldn't be able to speak with any
authority um to those parallels but your
question did make me think of
some interesting things that happen in
the the social media groups around the
sims that i think
um have some interesting interactions so
i think you know something that i i want
to do with the project in the future is
do
a little more content analysis of some
of those things so there are like i said
the facebook groups there's tumblr
groups around the sims there's discord
groups instagram twitter like the
community is all over the place but one
of the things that especially happens on
facebook and discord is that people
engage in a lot of storytelling there so
there um a lot of participants have
spoken about this which is why i'm able
to speak to it a little bit more even
though it wasn't the focus of the study
but people are like
crafting and creating their own
storylines with the sims and taking
screenshots of their sims and like
writing up short narratives about their
relationships in the game and all these
things and then post them to the
facebook group for other people to read
as like a kind of mix between like
fan fiction and short storytelling with
these like visual aids of the sims um so
i think that's really exciting to see
how people are like engaging that kind
of creative activity
um
i'm not sure if that entirely answered
the question you had another thing it
also made me think of is um streamers
there's a lot of
uh
streamers who who like play the game and
stream the sims to other people some of
them create and use their own mods some
of them don't but there is kind of an
interesting interaction there where
people are sharing a lot of their game
play for a game that is like a single
player game um so i don't know that's
like totally really to the question that
you asked but are some interesting
things that i've noticed as i've been
like diving more and more into the
community aspect of it
super thank you um who's next
uh mikey
uh hi alexandra i also can't turn on the
video
but
i think your talk was great so
we're doing a lot of similar work here
in the
mit game lab
and one of the things that
we often
think about and struggle a bit with is
uh
what how do you create sort of a
long-term change if you call me into a
community or in into a context and you
run a couple of workshops you make some
games together or something like that
but then uh you know you at some point
you had to leave and what you leave
behind
i was just curious about your your
thoughts on that
yeah i i really love that question um
so i one of the the frameworks that i
use that i had a very brief slide about
is called assets based design
um an asset space design right is is
trying to
respond to um
that's sort of uh hci framework that we
tend to teach our like early hci
students of need finding right so where
it's like when you're doing work you go
to a community you assess what needs
they have and you design to fill those
needs and then you leave like as you're
saying right where it's like suddenly
you've disappeared from the process
and asset space design is meant to look
more at
what are the active practices of the
community already right how do we treat
those as valuable how do we integrate
any designs or interventions that we
create as being embedded in the existing
practice of the community as a way to
make sure that those things last and
that they're more long-term
just like dropping an intervention on
people than like walking away and saying
like oh i did my study and i'm done it's
like trying to more actively work with
the the current practices um so that's
like the the general like framework and
theory i try to center when i'm doing
this kind of work
but i will admit like a very long-term
evaluation study is not something that
has been on on my
sort of research catalog history it is
something that i really want to do
especially as i'm starting to think
about moving into
educational spaces with
potentially younger game players but
has not come up directly in my work yet
so i would love to talk to you more
about this and maybe other ways that
we can collaborate with you for in the
game lab but uh thank you that was a
good answer and blow us to say hi as
well to everybody
yeah that sounds amazing and yeah thank
you for the question
boy now i wish my cats were allowed in
my study but they're not they're too
destructive and distracting
um we do have video now and as scott
points out now you can see us all
smiling and nodding vigorously we can
turn on our cameras if we if we choose
to um do we have any uh who's next
scott yeah
um
unless it's just me i think something's
up with your mic it's a little hard to
hear
yeah it almost sounds like you've got a
bad
input connection scott
exactly yes scott could you type it i'm
sorry that's frustrating
while you're typing though it is great
to see you that i'm glad you're able to
i've heard very great things from my uh
phd advisor jess hammer so
nice to you
okay we're just pausing for a second
well scott scott who claims he's not a
robot i think he might be a robot but
oh yeah he says his question might take
a few minutes so
um
from anyone else in the interim
ah marves
now uh with working video
um
yeah so uh for the games your lab has
been working on what um like platforms
do you use to develop um these games
typically and i'm also really interested
how you go through the prototyping
stages like when you feel that a game is
ready to move into like its software
version yeah i will say um i'm very
enamored of tabletop games and board
games um so i i that tends to be the
medium that i i like to stick with but
you know as someone who's uh joint
appointed in a computer science
department i recognize i probably need
to move into digital a little bit more
than i am currently
um i also i really like twine so a lot
of what i do is very narrative heavy and
it's you know it's open source it's a
very easy to use tool for for folks who
are making games for the first time um
i did uh that was one of my summer
ambitions that that uh worked for two
weeks and then failed which is i tried
to take a class on unity over the summer
and i was like nope didn't happen don't
have the motivation to like learn a
whole new thing right now but a lot of
my students um because we have a um
a really great games undergraduate
program at northeastern there's also a
master's program there's a lot of really
great talented game designers and
developers that i have a chance to work
with so the um
bypoc pwi game is currently being
developed in unity
um and in terms of prototyping i think
again it's like a very hci mindset to
want to stick with paper prototyping for
as long as you can just because it
allows you to do that thing instead of
like throwing your ideas out it's way
harder to throw your ideas out when you
had someone spend like a couple months
developing something on a very specific
platform with you know sort of very
specific mechanics built into it
um so i actually i didn't put it on any
of the slides but i
um
years ago published a paper at
meaningful play on a process for design
transformational games
um where i talked a lot about like the
iterative cycles you go through of um
doing research coming up with your idea
doing the necessary background turning
those ideas into a physical prototype
that you continue to play test
um and then kind of go back and forth
between those cycles so it's mostly just
incorporating like a very hci mindset of
iteration
and um
in terms of when you know you're done
uh that's where i think the
transformational framework really comes
in handy that's uh sabrina salba's work
um the website you can find it's like
transformational framework.com she's got
a free
pdf of her book available on the website
but she talks a little bit about like
how do you define a transformational
goal how do you make sure that you
define your audience concretely and how
do you define
the kind of change you want to see and
that helps with like
whether it's like formal research study
measures or just like anecdotal
observational behavior that you see when
someone's playing your game of like did
the change that i hoped would happen
actually happen
um so it's all very abstract i can give
a specific example um again from my like
early thesis work i made a
a board game that was about encouraging
curiosity in underrepresented students
in stem at the middle school level
um but that idea of like encouraging
curiosity is a very abstract big goal so
using the transformational framework we
like kind of drill down on like what's a
specific element of curiosity that we
can actually
see that we can actually measure
what we ended up going with was question
asking so then it was a very simple
matter of like every time we test the
game we can literally just like record
like how many questions
is each student asking when they play
the game
what are the quality of those questions
can we assess them for like whether or
not they're using aspects of like
hypothesis testing
or the scientific method or things like
that
so you find those like metrics that
you're looking for and then you can
start to track those over time each time
you do a play test
great thank you
ah shrewshi
all right this is actually thomas from
medium um so this is me again how's it
going uh so i'm interested in in in the
extent to which
mods can serve as a counter strategy to
creating media in the sense that you
know sure this you can create beautiful
things around the sims but first it
seems it's built as a race blind game
but it's also a game about capitalism
and the patriarchal family structure
right it's like and the their
constraints are very much they're the
ideological constraints so i was
wondering what are the limits to these
media making strategies for you
yeah that's a that's an interesting
question um
i will say
uh i don't know if this again
directly answers your question but
i do think i've seen how
in just this short time working on this
project right how much the modding
community
um
by creating this sense of community by
creating this fear of influence by
advocating and talking about the kinds
of game content they want to see in the
actual game has had an actual influence
on the games industry or like on if
we're just talking at least talking
specifically about the sims right so if
you look at the promotional material for
that that expansion pack i talked about
the spa day package it is very clearly
targeted towards um black sims players
right there the the content that's in
there that they're using like the
trailers are all using like megan the
stallion music it's like focused on
different black cultural hairstyles and
nails and things like that um so i do
think that like any of this kind of work
is actually quite powerful in showing
that there is at least a market and an
audience if we want to talk about it
from like a capitalist perspective um
but yeah i mean ultimately you're right
right like
the sims is a bit unique and that the
modding capability you can do in there
is actually pretty deep like you can
actually change the game mechanics uh
quite deeply one of the modifications
um
that is in the i believe the mccc uh
mod package is a a mod for child support
right so that is like a deep element of
gameplay that's not just like oh i
downloaded a a skin tone that wasn't
available before it's like actually
changing the structure of the gameplay
um so at least for that game in
particular there's actually quite a lot
you can do to change the structures but
in general
ultimately yeah it's like what you want
is to show that there's a market and a
need for these things that hopefully
changes the actual games industry into
making
that content
um can i follow up with a question so i
think that's a very interesting point
but i wonder because you know most
not all games can be modded so i was
wondering if you
if you if you if you found anything
about ea's discords around around
allowing mods for the sims i understand
they are loud since it seems too
um and they they seem to be very
powerful compared to other video games
where the mosque seems to be like you
know skins are like something very
superficial i was wondering if you if
you saw that as a core part of the
proposition that sims builds
i'm not sure i'm not sure i haven't
really read as much about what ea if
anything they've published about like
how they're making any of these
decisions i do think that would be an
interesting thing to explore in the
future to like try to see if we could
actually like get in contact with the
the folks who are like leading design
and development over there but i i don't
i wouldn't be able to speculate about
that
great thanks
um we do have a question from scott now
which i'll read aloud the film
television industry seems to have turned
a corner in sometimes centering by pack
voices even if it's purely for the
profit motive do you see comparable
movement in the commercial games
industry
that's a great question i mean i don't
i don't know that i have felt a huge
change
from
like industry with a capital i right
like really big game companies or things
like that but i do think i've seen a lot
of again that that sort of distribution
of power right you know there are a lot
more indie developers who are able to
crowdfund or get their own funding or
self-fund their own games or who are
able to make um prototypes or pilots of
their own game content and have found
an audience that's really eager for uh
games that are again by foreign about
people of color so i think
um
the the ability of people to like access
the audience directly and having that
power not just centered and located on
like bigger studios has i think created
the opportunity for a lot of change in
terms of the industry itself i hope that
they catch up um i was i i this semester
was teaching uh rapid idea prototyping
with the undergraduates um
at cmu and we were looking together last
week at um just like basic kind of
market game uh
stats from 2020 about like you know like
what games are making the most money and
and what are the most popular were the
most popular platforms um and that
spider-man expansion for miles morales
was like up there on one of the top 10
lists right like there is a huge market
that wanted that game that was excited
for it but it wasn't a standalone game
it was just an expansion so i think if
the
the games industry would see that
um hopefully that'll motivate some more
change but yeah it's a funny thing right
like it's
these bigger industries like you know
entertainment and games it is at a
certain point gonna largely be profit
driven and i think that
for some people that can be
pretty disheartening like i know that's
it was a tough thing for me to swallow
when i when i you know finally came
around to you know seeing capitalism
everywhere um
but in my um
uh critical race theory work right one
of the core tenets of critical race
theory is the idea of interest
convergence right and it means like
accepting the idea that
um social progress and justice
historically has not happened unless
it's in
the material interest of the majority
and again i
whenever i've shared kind of that
concept of interest convergence to the
audiences i've had a chance to speak to
i do try to encourage people like try
not to to let that bring you down into a
defeatist attitude it's more like having
that knowledge is always going to be a
useful tool in any kind of advocacy work
you do like capitalism
does drive a lot of the way things
happen at least in the states
and i think that that's
hopefully a useful leverage point but
it's not a difficult one to have to deal
with and confront
great thank you um
do we have anyone else
queued up or any other
games going up
i always have a question for all of you
which maybe folks can answer in the chat
or out loud i would love to hear more
about the games work that that y'all are
doing if you have like links to websites
or things that i can check out i'm
always excited to learn more and
find out what's been going on over uh
other places in boston
that's
that's um great and i and definitely um
i would encourage uh people on our
students to um email alexandra later but
also if anyone has any links they want
to share now or any uh just work that
they want to talk about
anybody else please any and all of that
i'll put my email in the chat also for
folks who don't have it thank you
that's great thanks
i'm just waiting a second
i think we might be
uh played out because it's the last day
of classes
and um
uh i think we might just be
a little tired and maybe need to end
colloquium a little a few minutes early
today um i'm just giving another second
for anyone out there but yeah i think we
may we may be done um
thank you so much alexander for your
time it was really uh terrific terrific
to to see your work to learn more about
it um i want to take just a minute for a
few announcements before sign off
um
let's see uh our this is our last
colloquium obviously of the semester and
we've got one coming up on february 3rd
uh with the title changing the subject
line notices by the way meet vera stark
in the making of black women's film
history that presentation is by samantha
shepard from cornell
so pretty excited about that we also
have um
some finalists for our job search in the
areas of computational and or industrial
studies who will be presenting
uh throughout february and perhaps into
march probably five uh five talks there
so keep an eye out for that we'll send
you updates when we have them um we've
got um someone speaking on spanish
language uh podcasting who is a current
neiman fellow so that should be great
we've also got raquel gates coming uh
still in the works but she said yes but
we're waiting to see if she's going to
be virtual or in person uh from columbia
university speaking on um probably on
melvin van peeble she she collaborated
with the criterion on their box set of
of melvin van keeble's uh films so um
just to give you a little taste of
what's coming in the spring
and uh
we will keep you posted as that moves
along uh thank you again everyone for
coming and uh to alexandra for your time
it's wonderful and
i'm disappointed thanks so much for
having me yeah this was fun
great thank you thank you so much